what if your surgeon told you you could
have smaller incisions
fewer complications and generally faster
recovery if a robot did your procedure
in today's health watch denise tells us
about a local medical group
honored as one of the best for robotic
assisted procedures denise
those are just some of the benefits
actually robotic surgeries are happening
more and more often for instance
at the saint rose siena campus of
dignity health they perform more than a
hundred of them
every month and it recently achieved
accreditation as a center of excellence
in robotic surgery
by an independent not-for-profit group
now of course there are challenges and
advantages of working on the forward
edge thinking of technology
surgeons are able to perform a broad
range of minimally invasive procedures
and oftentimes as you mentioned with
smaller incisions and shorter recovery
times
the accreditation of either meeting or
exceeding national standards
is the first in our state what this
means for us is we've taken steps to
invite an outside agency in to validate
and verify
that what we're doing is indeed surgical
excellence
and that we have taken that next step in
providing the
highest quality and safest care for the
patient the accreditation means that
saint rosciana campus is among the best
in the specialty
and the first in nevada so surgeons hope
it will give patients and their families
more confidence about
this type of approach to medicine by the
way some of the common robotic
procedures they perform
include cardiothoracic gynecologic and
urology surgeries